at this point.
Anybody who knows this show well knows that
I try not to be hyperbolic or exaggerated
when I say this is a concern.
That's something we have to worry about early
in the Corona virus pandemic.
I got emails from some of you said, David,
you're being hyperbolic about the risk of
Corona virus.
And it turned out that if anything, I was
understating the risk that Corona virus represented.
Now, I want to be crystal clear with you today.
The authoritarian paramilitary deployment
to Portland, Oregon, could well be just the
beginning.
A test case, a trial balloon for what is going
to be a massive authoritarian expansion over
the next several weeks leading up to the November
election.
Earlier this week, Donald Trump said he would
continue to send
federal law enforcement to more American cities,
including the unmarked cars and the unidentified
forces.
And Trump actually mentioned New York, Chicago,
Philly, Detroit, Baltimore, Oakland, as examples
of so-called, as he calls it, liberal Democrat
cities where he would be interested in sending
troops.
Now, understand that this is happening directly
counter to the requests of many of the state
and local leaders.
So, for example, the mayor of Portland, Oregon,
Ted Wheeler, does not want the troops there.
They are there anyway.
When Acting Secretary of Homeland Security
Chad Wolf was recently interviewed about this.
He was asked about the fact that many mayors
and governors don't want these troops there.
He said it doesn't matter.
Let's take a look at the clip.
It ours are just misinformed.
They're not accurate.
They don't understand the authorities.
And the responsibility of the Department of
Homeland Security has.
We protect over nine, almost nine thousand
federal facilities across the country.
We did that 10 years ago.
We did it long before the civil unrest started.
And we'll continue to do that.
And so I don't need invitations by the state.
State mayors or state governors to do our
job.
We're going to do that whether they like us
there or not.
That's our responsibility.
So, of course, the Hip-Hop.
Frisee is astounding in that the same people
who talk about states rights and local rights
are now saying we don't care that if the federal
government wants to be there and the governors
or the mayors don't, we're going to do it
anyway.
So then Donald Trump's press secretary, Kaley
McEnany, was asked about this yesterday and
she actually cited a specific statute and
essentially defended this action by saying
the federal government has property in these
cities and states and the federal government
is allowed to send troops to protect that
property.
Here she is yesterday.
And my second question is, where in the constitution
does the president derive the authority to
send federal law enforcement officers to the
streets of American cities against the will
of the elected officials in those cities?
Yes.
Well, what you're referring to is Portland
and 40 U.S. Code one three one five.
Gives DHS the ability to deputize officers
and any department or agency like ICE, Customs
and Border Patrol and Secret Service, quote,
as officers and agents, they can be deputized
for the duty of in connection with the protection
of property owned or occupied by the federal
government and persons on that property.
And when a federal courthouse is being lit
on fire, commercial fireworks being shot at,
it being shot at the officers.
I think that that falls pretty well within
the limits of 40 U.S. Code 13.
That's a matter of protecting federal property
with federal courthouse in the case of Portland.
Does he see limitations to that power?
How how how much how far does that power extend
into the into the streets of the city of Portland?
How we know what other limitations on that
authority to protect a federal project, a
law.
We believe that agents can conduct investigations
of crimes committed against federal property
or federal officers.
And in a case where you have someone shooting
off a commercial grade firework and then running
across the street.
We don't believe that that extends past our
jurisdiction.
So there's two parts here to discuss.
The first is she mentions 40 U.S. Code one
three one five.
That's called the Law Enforcement Authority
of Secretary of Homeland Security for protection
of property.
The next part is, are they merely protecting
property?
So what the law says is indeed that officers
and agents of DHS can be deployed in connection
with protecting property that the federal
government owns are occupied.
So there might be a property that is not federal
government property, but like a federal government
office or agency is based there.
So those would be the two scenarios, property
owned or occupied by the federal government.
There are two really important limitations
here, though.
One is a provision about authority outside
federal property were actually, it says, for
the protection of property owner occupied
by the owned or occupied by the federal government.
The secretary may enter
into agreements with federal agencies and
state and local governments to obtain authority
for officers and agents to enforce laws concurrently
with other federal law enforcement officers
and state and local law enforcement.
The secretary may do that if state and local
authorities want, but states don't want that
in the case of Portland and in Oregon.
And in fact, that's the next part that's at
issue here, which is that Caylee McEnany is
arguing if they have to chase someone, if
someone attacks a federal building and then
the troops have to chase that person across
the street, across the street, she believes
it is the opinion that she says the government
has.
They are still within their jurisdiction.
But the reality from the widespread reports
on the ground and the videos that we're seeing
are that things are happening not just across
the street, but even blocks from
so-called federal property.
So the framing they've set up is hanging by
a thread.
It only hangs together if you blindly accept
it.
But the truth is, the law allows federal troops
to be there concurrent with state and local
law enforcement.
And they may make an agreement, but the local
law enforcement does not have to make that
agreement.
And they are going very fast and loose when
it comes to the definition of federal property.
And that gets us to the point of all of this.
During yesterday's press briefing, Kaley McEnany
framed this all as violent actors are up against
law enforcement and Trump is on the correct
side.
Trump is going to send people in.
He's going to defend us.
It's all going to be great.
And she continued criticizing violence of
the protesters.
It's really important to understand a few
things here.
Number one, the
violent incidents have increased since the
troops went in.
Now, whether they're deliberately instigating
the troops or their mere presence is aggravating
the situation.
We can debate that.
I'm not taking a position on that yet.
But the whole point of this is number one.
This is a gambit that the more violence there
is on TV, the more the country will turn against
protesters and visa v that against.
Or rather in favor of Donald Trump.
The second piece of it is that this is all
a test case in Portland for deploying the
troops more broadly.
Trump has already given us a list of cities.
The deployment may happen up to and including
through Election Day in order to intimidate
people.
This is not a trivial matter.
This comes down to some of the fundamental
issues of state versus federal rights.
The role of law enforcement, due process,
jurisdiction.
And in the end, it's a desperate, cornered
president trying to get himself reelected,
fighting for his political life with any idea
that occurs to him.
He has restarted the coronavirus press briefings.
We covered it yesterday live.
He's sending in federal troops.
He's tweeting attacks at people.
He's holding press conferences where he just
reads attacks on Joe Biden off of a piece
of paper.
He's claiming he's aced cognitive tests that
Joe Biden and Chris Wallace wouldn't be able
to ace.
So at this point, this is a cornered individual
desperate for survival.
And on the show yesterday, as I said, a dangerous
trump, it a rather a desperate Trump is a
dangerous Trump.
And we should all be horrified by the potential
of this if they get away with this in Portland.
It's proof of concept that they can get away
with authoritarian crackdowns in other
cities and authoritarian crackdowns that will
last a while, meaning they will do more.
This is a test case.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at the Pacman and make sure
you're signed up for free to the daily audio
podcast yesterday.
Again, three weeks in a row.
I've said this on Wednesdays.
Yesterday was the best day ever for the audio
podcast.